brian tolander asks here's a subject
that may be at the heart of the great
divide we are seeing
getting wider in america cognitive
dissonance
two people looking at the same event and
walking away with extremely opposite
opinions
i'd love to hear your thoughts well this
relates directly to what we've already
been talking about yeah
um listen to rabbit hole
and it basically goes down a rabbit hole
of how we've arrived at this
place i think there's a broader
conversation about
confirmation bias and cognitive
dissonance you know and how the brain
works it is interesting that
that you know two different people could
watch the same news program
and walk away with completely different
ideas about it and then
i think the the larger problem is how
entrenched
we become in those ideas such that when
we're presented
with a counterfactual narrative no
matter how compelling that narrative
it it's irrelevant it doesn't matter
it's not going to move the needle in
terms of how that person is seeing the
world whether
it's the trump voter who can't be talked
out of voting for trump or
the super liberal person who you know
sees the world in a specific way
the the idea that you're going to change
these people's minds
i think is you know
we all know how difficult that is and
and what is that about
right like and i think
it has a lot to do with
again to bring it back to the beginning
of this conversation
disenfranchisement and disempowerment as
human beings were hardwired to
want to be part of a community of a
tribe
and we align ourselves with various
teams whether it's the philadelphia
eagles or
you know the the los angeles lakers like
look at sports and how we tribalize that
politics
are a close cousin of that and i think
as as
as um swats of the population
become progressively more
disenfranchised
there's a sense of lack of control and
i think there's an agency that develops
when somebody can latch on
to a certain tribe and craft an identity
around that
right this is who i am this is my
identity and
and you get strength from that no matter
who you are like if you're in the
democratic party
this is who i am this is what we stand
for this is our values
and i'm going to defend my
my membership status in this tribe
against
everything else no matter what facts
that i'm presented with
so then the question becomes how did we
become
so susceptible to these
silos these tribes and why do we cling
to them
so strongly and maybe it has something
to do with the fact that
the um connections that we have in our
own communities have been fractured
and this is taking the place of that
whether it's
the church or the 4-h club or whatever
it is that in the 1950s through the 70s
people
used to do within their respective
neighborhoods
a lot of that has gone away and we've
become suburbanized and
you know cul-de-sac eyes to such an
extent
that we no longer yeah we no longer have
those
connections that fabric that wedds us to
our local communities doesn't quite
exist in the way that it used to so
as human beings we're finding other ways
of doing that so we are doing it
digitally
and and maybe because we don't have
those in-person
tactile bonds that's why we're holding
on so tightly to
the identities that we fabricate that
are based on
ideologies rather than proximity what
you're talking what we're talking about
is
looking at something everyone's watching
the same thing and coming away with
different opinions but the fact is we're
not watching the same thing right so
that's also part of it that's part of it
yeah
yeah so we're watching different angles
of the same thing
yeah and um well there is no
there is no unified source of quote
unquote truth anymore
we're all self-selecting our information
silos we're all on different diets
basically also i think perception of
disenfranchisement is interesting
because
you know a lot of it is a perception
thing you know like where you perceive
yourself
in the greater whole and um
when you there's two ways of looking at
feeling small
in this big world to me
the healthy view is i'm a small fragment
of this great web
and i'm connected to all of it um and
it's all part of me and i'm part of it
and there's a there's a sense of
responsibility that comes with that and
there's a sense of
you know humility that comes with that
mm-hmm being the small
thing spec in this you know it's one
pixel yeah
in this in this tapestry or this picture
um you're just a couple zeros and ones
yeah that's in the matrix we're just
part of the
the great algorithm that green stream of
like
characters that's flowing down the
shangri-la
algorithm uh but then the negative view
of that is
why do i feel so small and these
[ __ ] are
such big shots you know and like what is
disenfranchisement like if you have a
place to live and some food on your
plate and
you're comfortable and you're warm or
whatever like like how disenfranchised
should you actually feel
so it's like there's all these moving
parts to the modern world now
and there's it's always been this way
you know we watched american beauty the
other night because
um we had to go back to the dvds because
our our cable company fumbled the ball
right on our move and so we were
watching that and there's a great scene
where the
uh where um what's the
guy video uh you know the the younger
wes uh yeah
what's his real name what's his name i
know you mean yeah um
the classic scene of that and he's his
dad is like reading the morning paper
and he's like what's going on dad and
dad goes this country's going straight
to hell
it's basically always been that yeah
just just to remind
our listeners and remind each other this
country's always been going straight to
hell like i'm sure in the revolution the
day after the revolutionary war ended
there was like someone complaining about
it and every generation
is told that like oh it's always been
this way every generation says that but
and then they say yeah but this time it
really is yes
this time well i feel like right now
maybe it is we can't end on that note
no but the point is is that there's
always that
kind of like this disenfranchisement is
a point of view i i always think of it
that way like
we're in charge of our emotional
perspective i mean don't you think i
mean like isn't that isn't that what you
you're trying to
we try to kind of tell people and tell
our kids and tell everybody it's like
that no one tells you no one can tell
you how you feel or how you're going to
react to something
you have control over that yes that
agency resides
within all of us and in a culture
and a world where we feel like that
that our agency has been stripped from
us it's important to realize that
there are still certain things that only
you have control over
you can't control the insanity of the
chaotic world
you can't control what other people are
going to do you can't control
the news cycle all you can control
is your reaction to all of that and how
you comport yourself
so it always goes back to mindfulness
the more mindful
that you can be the more
equanimous you can carry yourself
the better equipped you are to manage
whatever
problems you encounter whether they be
related to disenfranchisement or your
lack of sense of control
over your life always turn back
inward and as guru singh always says
less emotion more devotion
i love that right like
rather than getting all emotional about
things that you can't control
check yourself what are you devoted to
what are you cultivating inside of
yourself
that can lead to
greater self awareness self improvement
all you can control is yourself the path
forward is to be the best
version of yourself so that you're
equipped to handle
all those other things that you cannot
control
and the byproduct of that is you become
a force of harmony in this world and
like
dissonance dissonance in music is a tool
to be used
um to make people feel and then it
always wants to come back to harmony
like the piece of music always wants to
come back
dissonance always merges back so
that's a better note to end on because
it will if we
if we cultivate that yeah yeah agreed
[Music]
you